[Music]  rice cooked  process so we uh we do a first blanch  inside  dom perignon and a french champagne  vinegar we'll cool it down  and then we will then do the first fry  which is at 325 degrees  and then we will cool that down and  finish it off at 375 degrees  this process is really going to ensure  that it has a crispy exterior  and a fluffy interior  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  awful truffle and truffle inside these  fries  [Music]  [Music]  i mean it's been a rough year and a half  for everyone  and we need to have some fun now  we have everything from the world's  largest wedding cake  the world's most expensive ice cream  sundae  the world's most expensive burger the  world's largest  cup of hot cocoa we've done we've done a  lot  you